The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Professor Mindell
will be a little late today.
He's at a lunch for, I think,
department heads or something.
But he'll come meandering
in at some point.
But I'm the one that's
designated to
give the lecture today.
So I'm going to--
what I want to do today is to
talk about the general context
of the times in which
MIT was founded.
And one of the questions--
I think several of you raised
this question about, why was
MIT founded when it was?
Why did it happen at that
particular moment in history?
Because it wasn't the greatest
moment in history to be sure.
It took them, basically four
years from getting a charter
to actually opening the
Institute, to get started.
And even then, they
limped along.
It's a wonder MIT survived in
some ways because financially,
they were always in trouble
well through the 1890s.
Every year, they're just barely
making the budget.
And so it's not an easy
beginning, even though, in
many ways, from an educational
standpoint, a
revolutionary one.
Because it was a different breed
of cat that was being
founded here in 1861.
And I want to sort of give you
a background about what the
times were like.
How many of you had an American
history course,
either high school or--
so a lot of you have.
OK, that's good.
How many of have read Charles
Dickens A Tale of Two Cities?
What is the first line,
the famous first line?
"It was the best of times and
it was the worst of times."
And that could very well be the
same theme for the decade
that preceded the
founding of MIT.
It was the best of times, in
some ways, and yet it was the
worst of times in others.
And I think the best way to
start this is to say, history
itself is filled with irony
and contradictions.
And surely, the 1850s was one of
those times in history that
was filled with irony
and contradiction.
On the one hand, you had a
country that was intensely
nationalistic, intent on
expanding the boundaries to
the United States under a theme
that you've probably
encountered before called
Manifest Destiny.
It was the idea that America was
going to expand across the
continent, and perhaps even
sweep down through Latin and
South America.
There were some who really felt
that the United States
was destined to do that.
Intense nationalism.
And on the other hand, you
have intense sectional
divisions about, what were
you going to do with this
territory once you got it?
Was it going to be slave?
Was it going to be
free territory?
And that was the big question
of the 1850s, was the future
of slavery in the
United States.
And people were bitterly divided
along sectional lines
about the future of slavery
in the United States.
Well, when you look at the
United States from sort of the
best of times perspective--
I'm going to look at the best
of times side, and then look
at the worst of times.
But the best of times side,
what really is an economic
story and a technology story.
And that is, is that between
1839 and 1859, the United
States underwent a tremendous
spurt of growth.
Commodity output, for example,
between those two--
or over those two decades,
grew by something
like 57% per decade.
Not just over 20 years,
but per decade.
That's an amazing number.
That's like talking
about China today.
Even faster than
China in a way.
Also, railroad construction
begins
during the 1830s basically.
And by the late 1850s, by 1859,
the United States has
over 30,000 miles of railroad
in the country.
That mileage exceeded the total
mileage for the entire
world at that time--
Britain, France, Germany,
wherever.
So there was a tremendous
growth in railroad
construction.
And then, from a more
technological perspective,
when you look at the
manufacturing sector of the
United States, there were
tremendous technological
changes taking place
in manufacturing.
Not just of agricultural
equipment and cotton goods,
but also in things like metal
products, like firearms with
interchangeable parts, or
sewing machine that is a
derivative from that
new technology.
But there seemed to be this big
spurt in new technologies
that were very innovative
during this period.
And so much so-- and I'll talk
about it in a minute, that
Europe began to send observers
to the United States to see
what was going on here.
All of a sudden, this little,
nondescript develop--
the United States is a
developing country.
In 1820, it is really a
Hard to believe that today,
but it's true.
By 1850, that had changed.
And so during these decades
between the '20s and '30s and
up through the '50s, you're
seeing enormous
changes taking place--
railroads, manufacturing.
And then finally, in the
area of science.
The United States was beginning,
after being a
backwater--
basically, prior to the 1850s,
the United States was a place
where European scientists came
to collect things, collect
specimens of animals, or wood,
or plants, things like that.
No serious science was done
in the United States
prior to the 18--
what?
1830s I would say.
Some would dispute me on that.
Surely there were some
first-rate scientists in the
country, but not many.
By the 1830s and '40s, you begin
to see the emergence of
a serious science enterprise
in the United States led by
people like Joseph Henry who
is the first secretary--
yeah, I think he is the first
Secretary of the Smithsonian
Institution, which itself was
a scientific organization as
much a science enterprise
as it was a museum.
Today we think of it more as a
museum than that, but still
has it science projects there.
So there are people like Joseph
Henry, a fellow named
Alexander Dallas Bache, who was
running a survey of the
coastline of the United
States, a very
talented man of science.
I think he's the grandson of
Benjamin Franklin who is
arguably the first famous
scientist in the United States
because of his experiments
with electricity.
But they're few and
far between.
And so this science enterprise
is beginning to grow.
And I think it's in 1847 that
you see the establishment of
the American Association for
the Advancement of Science,
which was one of the key
organizations in this count--
still is.
Science Magazine is published
by their organization, and
it's considered to be the sort
of central source of
professional science in
the United States.
Finally, there's the educational
end of this.
And this is where
MIT comes in.
It's during the decade of the
1850s and '60s that you begin
to see this new thinking about
trying to shift higher
education away from an older,
traditional classic oriented
curriculum.
A classic, by that I mean an
educational process that
really emphasized the classic
languages, like Greek and
Latin, history, literature.
The world I come from
in many ways.
But there was this new movement
to try to insert the
study of science, and even
engineering, into this
educational process.
And it was not easily
received.
There was a lot of opposition
to that.
And it's in that context that
William Rogers comes along
with his vision of what this
polytechnic institute, this
new polytechnic institute
should be.
Sort of a revolutionary idea.
It was not something that
people said, oh,
yes, let's do it.
We're going to put up millions
of dollars to set you up.
It didn't happen that way, but
he was very persistent in
these goals.
He had started thinking about
this as early as the 1820s
with his brothers.
And it doesn't come to
fruition until 1861.
So it's a long time in the
making, even when it does get
started it's very shaky.
I'll talk about that part
of it next week.
But MIT is one of those new
institutions that tries to
combine science with more
practical or useful arts as
they were called
in that period.
And a new way that had not been
emphasized much in the
United States.
If you look at say, for example,
engineering schools
in the United States--
I mean, there were predecessors
to MIT in the
area of engineering.
Do you know which
ones they were?
What?
AUDIENCE: West Point.
PROFESSOR: West Point
is the first.
Yes, absolutely.
West Point is modeled after
the French Ecole
Polytechnique, and
was very much
influenced by French ideas.
Very mathematically-oriented
curriculum.
Very oriented towards
civil engineering.
Not mechanical as much
as civil engineering.
And the other school is what?
AUDIENCE: RPI.
PROFESSOR: RPI founded
in 1824.
And now, the current president
of RPI is an MIT graduate.
So we're all over
the place now.
This is an imperial operation
that we're
talking about, right?
No, not really.
But MIT's influence, of course,
has become very, very
significant in terms of
education influences over the
world in the last, what?
70 years or so.
Especially since World War II.
But those are four areas that
really are at play during this
period that mark an interesting
best of times way
of thinking about what
was going on during
this period of time.
And maybe the best way to
illustrate this is to talk a
bit about an event that took
place in 1851 in London when
the British held what was called
the London Crystal
Palace exhibition.
This was the first large
international exhibition that
we are familiar with today.
Or maybe not so much
your generation.
But when I was your age growing
up, there were all
sorts of these international
exhibitions that were taking
place, primarily built around
science and technology.
But this was the first,
the first big
one was held in London.
It was organized or sponsored
by the Prince Consort, the
husband of Queen Victoria,
Albert.
And it attracted all
the nations of the
world pretty much.
And at London, every nation
displayed their wares, things
they were proud of.
And the United States had
a lot of space there.
And the American delegate to
the exhibition got very
worried because they had too
much space to exhibit fairly
few things.
And he was writing back to his
sponsors in New York saying,
you've got to send
me more stuff.
Our display spaces
may be 25% full.
The Brits are making
fun of us.
And so they would send some
material over, and they'd put
it in display.
And the British magazine Punch,
which is sort of a
satirical magazine of the time,
was making great fun of
this backwater nation and
what it was displaying.
Plug tobacco from Henrico
County, Virginia, or apples
from Vermont, or apple
peelers from Ohio,
really mundane things.
When you were comparing this
with French exhibitions of
[? sieve ?]
china, or the Russian--
the famous Russian enamel--
what's the name of it?
It's very famous.
I never remember the name, but
it's a very famous, highly
ornate and extremely
expensive today.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, they're
like those.
They can be like that.
But it has a name and I
cannot remember it.
Doesn't matter.
High-end stuff was being
exhibited there.
The British were exhibiting
famous steam engines and
technologies, famous
locomotives.
And here's the United
States with its
apple peelers and stuff.
Well, eventually, the US
exhibit got filled up.
Punch was making a lot of
fun of what was there.
And then certain competitions
begin to be held.
And lo and behold, the
Americans started
winning some prizes.
For example, the harvester
guy from Chicago.
Cyrus McCormick exhibited his
reapers for cutting wheat,
grain, crops like that.
And he won a prize for beating
out in a competition several
other reapers that were
displayed there.
Charles Goodyear, Goodyear Tire
and Rubber Company, was
displaying boots, rubber boots,
and things that were
being made with his
vulcanized rubber.
And he won some recognition.
Another one, really quite an
interesting one, was a
locksmith from New York City.
A guy named Alfred Hobbs,
H-O-B-B-S, displayed his
padlocks that he had
made in New York.
And claimed that they
could not be picked.
And they had a competition
in London.
There was a very famous British
lockmaker, named
Joseph Bramah, who made
all the locks for the
big banks in England.
And they had put
up this prize.
I think it was quite a lot of
money, maybe as much as 500
pounds, which is still
a lot of money today.
And that was the prize if you
could pick Bramah's lock.
Well, damned if Hobbs didn't
succeed in picking the British
lockmaker's locks.
And that got a lot
of attention.
Because all a sudden, British
banks became vulnerable.
People started asking questions
about, well, how
secure are our faults
after all?
And immediately, Hobbs, being an
enterprising Yankee, moved
his business to London to try
to pick up on some of that
excess business that
was coming his way.
And then, there was a yacht
race that was held off the
coast of England.
And it was called--
well, I don't know that the
race had any name at that
time, but the yacht
America beat the
British yacht, Titannia.
And that was a serious blow
because Great Britain, at that
time, had the largest, the most
powerful and famous navy
in the world.
And here, these Yankees come
along and beat them in this
Yacht race.
So that was sort of a
slap in the face.
Finally, there were people like
Samuel Colt who were in
London exhibiting the revolving
pistols, for its day
a very innovative firearm.
And then finally, there was a
little company up in Windsor,
Vermont, named Robbins
and Lawrence.
You've never heard of
them before and you
probably never will.
But they exhibited six rifles,
military rifles, that were
made for the US Army
that were made with
interchangeable parts.
And they were taking them apart,
mixing the parts, and
putting them back together.
And everyone was very impressed
about that.
And again, no one in Europe
was making guns with
interchangeable parts
at the time, so that
aroused a lot of interest.
And that, in turn, prompted the
British government to send
a committee to the United
States to explore--
and the name of the committee
is self-explanatory.
It's called the Committee on
the Machinery of the United
States of America.
That covers a lot
of territory.
Not just gunmaking machinery.
They land the New York
in April of 1854.
They leave in August.
And then the process, they come
immediately to New England.
Well, why New England?
Because at that time, Boston
in the New England area was
the center point of American
industry at that time.
And so they immediately
head to New England.
And where do they go first?
They go to the Springfield
Armory out in Springfield,
Massachusetts, which was not
just famous for making guns
with interchangeable parts--
and it's a government-owned
armory.
It also was very famous as being
sort of a clearinghouse
of technological information.
If you got a letter from your
congressman or some dignitary,
they would give you access to
this place to examine all of
its machinery, gauging systems,
patterns, drawings,
and you could make copies
of this stuff.
And it was free.
So the Brits took advantage
of that right off the bat.
So they went to Springfield
immediately, took a good look
see what was going on there.
Then they proceeded to make a
tour of the whole eastern
coast of the United States
as far south as Richmond.
And then from Richmond, they
went west out into the
Pittsburgh area--
Wheeling, West Virginia,
Pittsburgh.
And then they swung further
north around the Great Lakes
up into Buffalo, New
York, and then came
across upstate New York.
I believe on the New York
Central Railroad.
It was just build at the time.
If not, they would've used the
Erie Canal, which parallels
pretty much that railroad.
And then, they dipped back down
in New England and spent
a lot of time in New England.
Ending up buying $105,000 worth
of machine tools for
really, the reconstruction of
the British Enfield Armory,
which was the main government
armory in England.
Now, that's a significant moment
because up until this
point, pretty much the United
States had been a borrower of
technology and technological
information.
This is one of the big moments
in which the shift had begun,
in which new technologies and
information were beginning to
make their way from the United
States to Europe.
It was sort of a wake-up call.
In a way, I think parallel to
what's happening today with
reference to the growth
of large economies
in China and India.
All of a sudden, people are
turning their heads and
saying, hey, something's
happening there.
I heard on the radio this
morning that in terms of
economic prowess, that China
will outgrow the
United States by--
well, maybe not in my lifetime,
but in yours.
By the 2020s, or thereabouts.
That's significant moment.
Big shift.
Whether it happens is
another question.
Who knows?
But in any case, that moment
in 1851 indicates why there
was this feeling that these are
really interesting times.
These are the best of times
from an engineering and
technology point of view.
The economy is moving, and
it's moving very fast.
There was only one
damper on this.
It was a panic that took place
in 1857 that slowed--
it actually slowed production
for a while, but it never
stopped it.
And other than that, this was
a moment of great change in
the United States.
Now, compare that with the theme
of the worst of times.
What's going on in
the same period.
And this is pretty much very
similar to what you-- if you
read that chapter I wrote on the
1850s in the textbook, you
get the drift.
I don't need to go into great
detail about it, but it's all
about the slavery issue in the
United States and the sort of
sectional divisions that
are taking places
as a result of this.
And it begins--
if you're to talk about, well,
when does the big debate about
slavery take place and when
does it originate?
It was being discussed as early
as the 1780s when the US
Constitution was
being debated.
How are slaves going to be
counted in terms of voting and
things like that?
And then later, in 1820, the
first big political issue
concerning slavery came up
with reference to the
admission of Missouri into the
Union as a slave state.
And the great compromise that
was achieved at that time was,
OK, you bring in Missouri as a
slave state, we'll bring in
Maine as a free state.
And that sort of tit for tat
sort of balance maintained
itself up until 1850, when
California was brought into a
Union as a free state
and nothing came
in as a slave state.
Why is that significant?
Because it gave free states the
edge in the US Senate in
terms of voting.
Each state got two
US senators.
So that meant the Senate now was
under the control of free
state politicians.
That's a big deal.
But between the Missouri
Compromise and 1861, when the
war comes, there are a series
of cascading crises that I
would say create a psychology
of crisis by the 1850s that
make things worse, and
worse, and worse.
And more tension and more
division, so much so that you
have South Carolina seceding
from the Union in December of
1860, right after Lincoln's
election as president.
Why Lincoln?
Why was Lincoln such
a feared figure?
Well, he represented the
Republican Party.
This is the same party we have
today, Republican Party.
It was created an 1854,
the origins of it.
And the Republican Party started
out, one of its chief
points was no expansion of
slavery into new territories.
It wasn't, let's get
rid of slavery.
It was just, we're against the
expansion of slavery into new
territories that would
come into the
United States as states.
But Lincoln stood for that.
He was not an abolitionist
in the sense of immediate
abolition of slavery
everywhere.
He was not that.
He eventually would come to that
during the war, but not
at the beginning of the war.
And just to talk about Lincoln
in this context is extremely
interesting.
Because he is--
you're bringing me flowers?
How thoughtful?
Anyway, he's a masterful
politician, who really--
in many ways, sort of skirts
around the slavery issue and
uses it when he has to, to make
policy with reference to
pursuit of the Civil War.
But prior to the Civil War, you
have a series of crises
that really bring it on.
And I would say if you were to
ask me, well, what were they?
I'll give you my
three top ones.
I'm not going to relay
every one of them.
You can look them up.
But one is definitely the famous
Wilmot Proviso of 1846.
This was a bill that was put up
in Congress by a Free Soil
Democratic, congressman
from Pennsylvania.
Actually, from my hometown.
I'm very proud of David Wilmot
because he was the initiator
of this Wilmot Proviso.
And what did that say?
Well, it said-- basically, it
was attached to an army
appropriations bill for the
Mexican war, which said that
if the United States is to
secure any territory from
Mexico as a result of this
war, that territory, if
organized into states,
has to come into the
Union as free states.
Well, you can understand why
Southerners got very upset
about that.
And that issued a heated debate
that continued right up
until 1861.
After the Wilmot Proviso, it
seemed that every Congress
there was something brought to
the forefront that was about
the extension or non-extension
of slavery.
Another moment that was very,
I think, had a great deal of
influence was the publication
of Harriet Beecher Stowe's
novel, Uncle Tom's Cabin.
That appeared in 1851, the
same year that I just
mentioned with reference to the
best of times, the great
London Crystal Palace
exhibition.
That got a huge readership.
And as a result of her critique
really, in this novel
of slavery and how evil it was,
turned a lot of people
against the idea of
slavery and it's
being a righteous cause.
So that had a lot of feedback.
There was actually reward put
on her head in the South.
I think it's in South Carolina,
which is one of the
more hard line states
at that time.
But she was not a
person who was--
she dared not travel South of
the Mason-Dixon line because
anyone could shoot
her or whatever.
She was a woman that
was wanted.
And so her book, which started
out as newspaper articles,
eventually got a huge
readership.
I think next to the Bible, it
was the largest-selling book
of the 19th century.
That's how big this thing was.
Huge.
And then finally, I think the
third point I would say that
really, probably was the straw
that broke the camel's back,
was when the abolitionist
John Brown raided
Harpers Ferry, Virginia.
Now, Harpers Ferry today is
located in the panhandle of
West Virginia.
It's about 60 miles west
of Washington, DC,
on the Potomac River.
But at that time, Harpers Ferry
had one of the two large
national armories,
government-owned armories there.
And the reason he raided Harpers
Ferry was that he
wanted to seize firearms that
were being stored there.
Some 10,000 guns were
in storage there.
And arm slaves, and start a
slave rebellion against slave
masters because they were right
on the Virginia border.
Literally, you cross the river
and you were in Virginia.
And the Brown Raid really sent
the fear of the Lord
throughout the South.
I mean, I've written a book
about Harpers Ferry, and I
know what the local
reaction was.
People became totally
paranoid.
As far as they were concerned
after that raid, there was an
abolitionist lurking
behind every tree.
And they organized militias and
they did runaway hunts.
And it was very much like a
vigilante moment in the sense
that the whole South became
vigilantitized, if that's a word.
It's not a word.
What would it be?
Vigilant--
vigilized?
No, I don't know.
Anyway, I will just change the
sentence and say, vigilante
groups grew by leaps and
bounds after that raid.
AUDIENCE: Vigilant.
PROFESSOR: Vigilant.
There you go.
Paranoid vigilance.
Anyway, following that, of
course, that took place in
October of 1859.
The following year was
an election year.
And that's when Lincoln
gets elected.
Well, you can imagine why this
became such a heated election.
There were, what?
There were at least three or
four candidates in that
election, and Lincoln wins not
with the majority vote.
But he gets him enough to get
himself elected in the
electoral college.
And then you have, within a
month of Lincoln's election,
you have that secession
crisis.
South Carolina goes out on
December 20, and it's followed
by around seven other deep
Southern states.
Interestingly, the northern tier
of Southern states, like
Virginia, do not go
out until later.
Virginia and Tennessee,
they don't secede
until at least April.
I think it's April that
Virginia secedes.
But by then, within
days, war comes.
And the irony of all this
is that the war--
the Sumter--
the attack on Fort Sumter, which
signals the beginning of
the American Civil War, is four
days after William Barton
Rogers got his charter from the
state of Massachusetts to
establish the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
Not a good time to be getting
into the education business
because all eyes were shifted
on the secession crisis.
All budgets were being shifted
toward getting ready in
preparation for war.
And all of a sudden, there's
this big, national crisis in
which this new fledgling
institution is supposed to be
taking root.
And it doesn't really take root
until the war ends when
students are admitted.
And I think it's the
spring of 1860--
early 1865.
So literally, MIT is
established in the
midst of civil war.
And just to follow that out--
well, no, I won't follow
it out anymore.
Those are basically--
that's the good and the bad
story of the 1850s.
It's a very complex time.
And it's one of those historical
moments that is
filled with tension, and change,
and reorientation.
It's just a critical
moment in history.
And then, it's capped by the
outbreak of the Civil War,
right at the moment when this
place is being founded.
I really wonder sometimes how
in the world Rogers held it
all together.
He must have worked very hard
to try to just keep things
together enough so that the
Institution itself could
survive through that
war, and then
open up to a few students.
Not a huge number, I
forget the number.
It's under a hundred when
they first open up.
One thing to note, however,
is that he's a
progressive in many ways.
He's very much in favor of women
coming to the Institute
at a time when most colleges
were not in favor of that.
It was still an institution that
was dominated by males,
there's no doubt about that.
Women tended to be part-time
students, or they were called
"special students." That term
is still used today,
"specials." And it's not until,
I would say the 1970s
or thereabouts, that women began
to grow in proportion to
the number of men at MIT.
But William Barton Rogers was
always in favor of allowing
women to come to the Institute,
which in itself was
sort of innovative.
He tended to be on the right
side of a lot of issues.
For example, when Darwin
announced--
I'm giving away my bias
against Darwin.
But when Darwin published The
Origins of Species, of course
he got a lot of flack from
scientists around the world.
One of whom was Louis--
I never pronounce
his name right.
AUDIENCE: Agassiz.
PROFESSOR: Aggasiz.
I want to say "Ah-ga-zay."
It's Aggasiz.
There's a school that used to be
called the Agassiz School.
You'd think I'd remember it.
But he was at Harvard, and he
was a big critic of Darwin's.
Our friend Rogers, on the
other hand, stood up and
debated, and really defended
the Darwinian idea in the
United States.
He was one of the primary
defenders in this area.
So that counts in his
favor, I think.
A man who pioneered the field
of geology in the United
States, we'll talk a little bit
more about that next week.
But he's an important
intellectual force.
And he had this vision for a new
type of institution that
he wanted to see established,
which eventually became the
place that we're sitting
in today.
So I must tell you that I didn't
know much about William
Barton Rogers four years ago.
I knew he was the founder
of MIT, and I
didn't know much else.
And then, there was a book that
was being published for
the 150th anniversary of MIT by
one of my colleagues and he
asked me to write an
essay about Rogers.
And my answer primarily
was, crap.
Why do I have to do that?
Because I didn't know anything
about the subject.
And I thought, somebody
else should do this.
But I agreed, primarily because
he's a good colleague,
and a friend, and it's
hard to say no.
And at that point, I started
reading up on
the history of MIT.
And the more I read about this
place, the more amazed I am
about what it is, what it stands
for, how it developed.
It's an amazing story.
So I'm hoping that during the
term you'll get bits and
pieces of this story, and kind
of pull them together.
We don't have a history
of MIT.
There is no single book that you
can pull off the bookshelf
and say, this is the
history of MIT.
That doesn't exist.
There are lots of bits and
pieces of history of MIT, but
no one book that does that.
And somebody should do it, I
think, because it's really--
it's an important institution.
I know I'm proud to be here
and I think you are, too.
I know you work very hard.
And you probably bitch and
moan about that a lot.
For good reason, but it's worth
it when you get the
education, get the Brass
Rat and leave here.
You've got something you can
be proud of, too, I think.
It's quite a place.
And just, the more I learn about
it, the more amazed I am
about all that's
happened here.
And the story even gets more
dramatic the further we come
to the present.
And David Mindell knows a lot
about that part of the
Institute's history.
So that's where we are for
today's talk or lecture.
Now, you want to take a break
for a few minutes and I will
collaborate with my colleague
about the discussion.
We'll have a little discussion
about this and
move on from there.
OK?
Huge numbers.
By my count, roughly
750,000 died.
Now, that's not necessarily
battlefield deaths, it's
including people whose wounds
killed them after the war was
over, things like that.
So it's a really bloody war.
And I don't know what percentage
of the population
that is, but it's a significant
number.
It would be like losing--
say, if we were to have a
similar war today, it would
probably be in the order of
losing maybe 1, 1.5 million
soldiers in the war.
Would we stand for that today?
That's pretty bad.
It's bad enough when you're
losing thousands, but when
you're losing over a million,
that's getting into a whole
different realm.
As you say, it's one of these
moments that is not apparently
the best time.
And yet, you see it coming.
What are the earmarks
of knowing that it
was the right moment?
What was Roger's thinking when
he was thinking about trying
to establish a polytechnic
institute?
As I said earlier, he starts
thinking about this as early
as the late 1820s.
He's very close to his
brother, Henry.
Interestingly, Henry's full name
was Henry Darwin Rogers.
Their father was an
immigrant from--
I believe they came
from Scotland.
Or maybe Northern Ireland,
I'm not sure.
But he clearly was familiar with
the Darwin family, which
was not just-- this would have
been Charles' father, I
suspect, or someone like that.
But in any case, here are these
two brothers talking
about the need for a polytechnic
institute.
They're not engineers.
They're scientists.
William Barton Rogers, I guess
if you would have asked him in
1825, what are you?
He would have probably
called himself--
what would be the word for
physicist in those days?
DAVID MINDELL: Natural
philosopher.
PROFESSOR: Natural philosopher,
yeah.
When he first established the
Institute, one of the courses
he thought was basically
the physics course.
That didn't last for long
because his obligations were
so many that he had to hire
somebody to do it.
And then he made the shift
during the 1820s and '30s into
the field of geology.
He was one of the early
geologists in this country.
And really makes his name in
that area that we can talk
more about next week.
But when you look at the period,
there's a lot of stuff
going on that would have
indicated, yes,
we need these places.
But we're right in the middle
of an Industrial Revolution.
We'll see from the essay that
I've written-- did you read
the essay I wrote yet?
That's next week, I think.
You'll see in there that he
conducts a geological survey
of the state of Virginia, which
proved to be a political
nightmare for him because of the
fighting that went on over
what should be his
primary mission.
That state is divided between
Eastern and Western interests,
and they were vying with one
another about, what should
this survey really be about?
He got caught in the
middle of that.
And in the process of trying
to make everyone happy, he
doesn't have enough assistance
of people who are technically
competent to do the surveys,
and the note-taking, and
things like that.
Clearly that's one impetus to
him, was starting to think
about, boy, do we need people
who are trained to be able to
do the sort of work that's
necessary to explore our
industrial resources, or
actually go into these
industrial areas and
actually run them.
That's one of the sources of
his idea about MIT were--
he wasn't calling it
MIT in those days.
The name MIT for him doesn't
emerge until the late 1850s.
Much later.
He's teaching in Virginia
this time.
He's born and raised
in Virginia.
His dad taught at William
and Mary College.
And so he's raised in
the slave society.
And yet, surely-- well, he
marries a woman from Boston,
but he's never--
I've never seen anything in his
writings that indicated
that he was pro-slavery.
Quite the opposite.
He was opposed to slavery.
And so he found Boston a much
more acceptable climate to be
living in once he moved
up here in the 1850s.
But this business about why
did he do it during--
he gets the idea and starts
pushing for it around 1859.
Why then?
Clearly, there are needs,
no doubt about it.
But you got to ask yourself,
well, to what extent was he
aware of the degree
of the political
tensions in the crisis?
It was two years before
the war came.
And that slavery issue
had been going on
for how many years?
20, 30?
You can count back as many
as 60 years, or more.
So I could well imagine that
someone like Rogers would be
thinking, well, yeah.
There's a lot of tension
here, but it's not
going to happen now.
He was probably taken by
surprise would be my guess.
DAVID MINDELL: Really?
There's another way
to read it where--
PROFESSOR: Did I ask you?
DAVID MINDELL: I told
you I was going to
sit here and listen.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, he's going to
sit over there like a jaybird.
DAVID MINDELL: Where he's
married to an abolitionist.
Boston, in general in New
England society, is--
there's a lot of abolitionist
fervor.
People are extremely political
active-- that's one thing he
likes about New England.
He goes on vacation with Emma
Savage's family and they have
all these political
discussions.
So then you could say, maybe he
sees the founding of MIT as
a political act.
PROFESSOR: That's interesting.
DAVID MINDELL: And it's
interesting then to think
about what kind of political act
it might be if it was one.
PROFESSOR: That's interesting.
So a political act in the sense
that it would be a place
that was doing a new style of
education to be sure, coupling
it with reform sentiment that
is so rampant in Boston--
Boston is the center the
abolitionist movement.
William Lloyd Garrison's paper
was centered here in Boston,
so he's pushing at a button here
that's very interesting.
I hadn't thought about that.
DAVID MINDELL: Or Rogers has
a vision of a world where
technology is important.
The people who engineer and deal
with it are important,
which wasn't really
the case then.
And that that's a world that
he sees as a counter to the
world that he left in the South
where it's agrarian.
It's much more political in
different kinds of ways.
And he wants to educate a cadre
of technical experts who
can run the world in a more,
maybe dispassionate way than
he found in the South.
PROFESSOR: Oh, god.
That's really interesting.
You should be leading
this discussion.
That's very interesting now,
educating a cadre of
individuals who would be capable
of sort of leading the
world in a different way.
What does that mean to
educate this cadre?
What kind of individual would
you want to be educating?
We know that MIT was founded to
try to combine the useful
arts, or what we would describe
as engineering today,
with science, the pursuit of
science, trying to bring them
together, have them interact,
and produce something--
a student is a special
product in a way.
But what about that ultimate
vision of creating a cadre of
graduates that are going to go
out and shape or reshape the
world to a new way of thinking
about things?
That's very interesting.
Let me push it a little bit
further and say this.
Up until the founding of MIT in
1861, there had been this
process of industrialization,
which was centered around
transportation, building
railroads, and creating
factories for producing
everything from boots and
shoes, to cotton textiles,
to sewing machines.
And these things were
accompanied not only by the
machinery, and the labor forces,
and things like that,
but they were also accompanied
by an attempt to try to learn
how to manage them.
So many of them were
big enterprises.
Railroads are employing
thousands of people.
Pennsylvania Railroad employed
1,200 people by
1859 I would say.
And factories, like the Lowell
Mills, are employing 200 or
300 in each building, let alone
the whole town, which
would be well over 1,000.
If you're seeing management
emerging alongside of this
educational process, it would
mean to me that Rogers has got
to be interested not just
in teaching science and
engineering, but also trying
to get students to think
about, how do you manage these
enterprises once you go out to
work in them?
And what is that all about?
What is management really about
when you talk about
managing things?
Coordination and control.
It's trying to control things.
That's an important part
of this business.
That brings a different
dimension to the--
now, they're not teaching that
in liberal arts colleges or
the classical curriculum
colleges.
They're creating "gentlemen."
They're not creating ladies
because there were very few
ladies in any schools, but
they are creating gentleman
to go on to law school,
or stuff like that.
So there's a different
breed of cat being
made in these schools.
If what David says is true, it's
as much about learning
how to control things
as it is learning
about how to do things.
Learning and doing also involves
learning how to
impose some control over that.
What are the problems that might
arise with that sort of
enterprise?
I think it's an interesting
question because if you look
at it from, say labor.
What's the labor management?
That's the dichotomy is
labor management.
MIT ends up on the management
side, I would say, more than
on the labor side of things.
This is right at the moment when
you're beginning to see
serious labor management
divisions.
I didn't talk about that in
my lecture, but definitely
happening during these years.
So MIT is sort of adding to the
strength of the managerial
side of technological change
and science then to the
so-called labor-oriented
rank and file side.
That, in itself, is a very
interesting statement about
what the Institute is about.
Openly about.
Don't need to apologize
for it, but need to be
aware of it I think.
That in establishing that sort
of school, you're going to be
more interested in those
managerial sides of
controlling and coordinating
large enterprises.
Where are the early graduates
going from MIT?
Now, you haven't read
about this, so
I'll answer the question.
Many of them are going to large
railroad companies.
They're sending a lot of their
young graduates off to work as
engineers on railroads.
Not running locomotives, but to
build lines, coordinating
control of the operation of the
railroad, stuff like that.
That's where a lot of these
young men are going.
So it's an interesting
thought about that.
DAVID MINDELL: One of the words
that caught me in the
conversation, and in the
responses, was the sense that
the founding of MIT was
inevitable in any way.
And maybe we made it seem that
way with some of the material
we've been looking at, but if
you zoom out one level--
and even, the industrialization
of America
maybe looks inevitable
in some way.
But it was not inevitable,
and was incredibly
fraught with conflict.
There was nothing like the kind
of presumption today that
technological development
equals economic progress
equals social progress.
And it's not too much of an
exaggeration to say the entire
American Civil War was fought
over different visions of what
America might be.
One being an agrarian, rural,
essentially non-industrialized
economy with the kind of social
order of slavery and
racial divisions.
And also, very much a
traditional class structure
around that.
And the other being much more
represented by the North,
industrialized, very
managerial, very
technological, heavily
railroads.
No small number of the leading
Union generals were railroad
executives before the war,
including McClellan.
And so if you look at
the war in that--
and all of the tensions leading
up to the war, and it
was pretty explicit
at the time.
Thomas Jefferson very
much viewed--
this is 40, 50 years before, but
viewed the country in this
kind of agrarian way.
We weren't going to make the
same kind of mistakes that
England made and have a dirty
industrial economy.
If you look at the war in that
way, then the founding of MIT
is very much almost like a move
in a chess board for one
side, which is obviously the
one toward, this is what an
ordered industrial,
Northern-dominated
economy could be.
And it happens to be the side
that won, but it was 3/4 of
million people had to die
between here and there, much
the less another half century
of conflict over--
Roe's books about how half the
problem was just trying to get
people to come to work at the
same time every day, and work
through the planting season.
Because you couldn't have a
factory unless you get people
to do that.
And that was 30 years of
conflict just to get
people to do that.
PROFESSOR: There's a phrase
about when you start making
machinery and putting them
in things that are called
factories, which are new.
We're familiar with them, but
people in the age had never
seen these things before.
They just knew that there was
good money to be made.
You could make cash wages
by working in
one of these places.
It was inviting in that sense.
But on the other hand, going in
there to work and having to
work to regimented hours, and be
expected to produce so much
stuff during the day.
One of the managers of an early
textile operation said,
this is like trying to put
a deer in a harness.
Imagine that.
Just think about putting
a deer in a harness.
That just doesn't work.
There's going to be a lot of
bucking and resistance, and
going nowhere sort of.
And so it's a tricky business,
no doubt about it.
David mentions just getting
workers to work according to
clocked hours.
We're so used to--
I mean, either we're wearing
watches, or you've got it on
your cell phones, all
of us are very
time-oriented in this age.
But 200 years ago, very few
people, only wealthy people
could afford to own
a pocket watch.
They were really expensive.
And only the wealthiest
households had these tall
clocks in their hallways
and stuff like that.
Most people didn't have
time-keeping devices.
That comes in with the coming
of industry, with factories
and things like that.
In fact, it's factories that
start making the early, cheap
clocks you can buy for
a couple of dollars.
There's a famous traveler
who goes in--
it's a British visitor who
travels in the Southeastern
part of the United States,
writing in the late '20s,
early '30s thereabouts.
And he's writing about--
I'm going to take that back,
it's a woman traveler.
Sorry.
Traveling in these areas.
And one of the things she
notices is that--
and she comes into Arkansas,
which is pretty much in the
deep recesses of the United
States at that time.
Well, Arkansas, West of the
Mississippi, 1832 or
thereabouts, is really
in the deep recesses.
That's frontier country.
That's what I mean by that.
Are you from Arkansas?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: I didn't mean to
insult Arkansas people.
But in any case, she makes this
comment about, I travel
around the countryside and I
enter these cabins with dirt
floors, hardly a stick of
furniture, and there's a
Connecticut clock sitting
on the fireplace mantle.
They'd rather own a clock
than owning furniture.
That was unheard of
50 years earlier.
You couldn't afford something
like that.
And yet, boy, they were buying
them like crazy.
Be it these clocks are being
made in Connecticut, and then
taken literally, in wagons
across the country, and sold
off by the thousands to people
for a couple dollars a piece.
Your grandparents or parents
may have some of them.
They're old brass works clocks
that when they strike the
hour, it'd wake the dead.
They're very, very available,
even today.
But that sense of time and time
orientation as a new dimension.
People are not used to
it and they go on
strike in many instances.
They try to resist this.
And that's part of that
management, trying to get that
control that didn't exist.
No one knew about it.
Jefferson refers to the slavery
issue in the 1820s as
trying to hold a wolf
by the ears.
He is very concerned about the
future of slavery in America.
He never remits his slaves
as far as I know.
But the other wolf that was
being held by the ears at this
time has to do with labor
management, the problems that
were going to emerge.
Lowell, a great industrial
city in the 1820s was
considered to be a utopia.
It was a place that people
wanted to work at.
But by the 1840s, there are
all sorts of strikes
going on out there.
Protesting time rules and the
cost of living in boarding
houses, and stuff like that.
So it gets very complex.
And Rogers is living through
all of this, and seeing it,
and trying to come to some
conclusion about, how do I
enter into this educational
process?
How do I make it better
supposedly?
So it's a complex, interesting
era that is the era
that he lives in.
Now, there's another question
that was raised today, but how
did Rogers get the money
to find benefactors?
When you graduate from MIT,
MIT Alumni Association is
going to get your name
and address.
And several times a year you're
going to get mailings
from them saying, we need
your benefaction.
You need to help us keep
the Institute going for
fellowships, and scholarships,
and a new swimming pool, or
whatever it may be.
It's through that sort of giving
that is very important
to the operation of
any school today.
It was important
to Rogers then.
When you read my essay next
week, the title of the essay
is called "Godspeed the
Institute." It's in
quotations.
That's actually a quote from
an early benefactor of MIT.
He was a doctor here in Boston,
Harvard graduate, a
surgeon, made a lot of money
investing in local
industries--
railroads, textile mills.
Made a lot of money, and
he had money to give.
And rather than giving it to
Harvard, he gives it to MIT.
It's like $40,000, quite a lot
of money for that time.
And I can imagine how people
at Harvard felt about that.
Because he was turning on a
different direction here.
But he was interested in sort
of the practical hands-on
orientation that Rogers was
trying to develop in the
Institute with reference to
bringing science and the
useful arts in contact
with each other.
But that was one form.
Where else would you be getting
money to run a place
like this early on?
AUDIENCE: From the military?
PROFESSOR: Well, military.
Who said military?
OK.
Say a little more.
Military in what way?
How would you imagine that?
AUDIENCE: There's a lot of
government contracts maybe
back then, I don't know.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, absolutely.
It's not so much military money,
but it's war-related.
Legislation that's passed by
the Lincoln administration.
Interestingly, Lincoln is a
Republican, a member of the
Republican Party.
Early member of the
In those days, Republican
Party was all about big
government, believe it or not.
Today it's just the
other way around.
What the Democrats were in the
1860s, the Republicans are
today, and vice versa.
So in Lincoln's day, one of the
big proposals that was put
up, and you'll read about it
next week is, trying to get
grants for the establishment
of state universities that
would emphasize mechanical and
agricultural pursuits.
Texas A&M. A&M, Agricultural
Mechanical colleges.
I went to Penn State.
That's a land-grant school.
All of these schools come out
of a piece of Civil War
legislation called the Morrill
Land-Grant Act, which
literally put up money--
it gave money to each state
based on the number of
representatives they had in the
House of Representatives
and the number of US
senators they had.
I think it's 30,000 acres
per representative.
They'd give that land to the
state legislature, which in
turn could keep the land for as
long as they want, or they
could turn it into script and
sell it to investors.
Where was that land located?
This is a sore point for those
of you who are from the
Midwest, especially places
like Minnesota,
Iowa, places like that.
Most of the land was from
out on that area
and not in the East.
There were some plots,
but not much.
And that land was used by the
Massachusetts legislature to
parcel out in terms of
government grants.
Here's government giving out
money, in effect, to places
like MIT, University of
Massachusetts are the two main
beneficiaries of that.
MIT is a land-grant college.
Did you know that?
MIT emerges right out of this
land-grant tradition, and it's
arguably one of the first.
It may be the first land-grant
college in the United States,
which we kind of don't recognize
because MIT is a
private corporation
at the same time.
You would think, this is not
Penn State or it's not Ohio
State, which are both
land-grant schools.
Those are state universities.
This is a private corporation.
And yet, its initial funding,
a big part of it, both the
land over in Boston and money
from the legislature, came
from the state through this
piece of national legislation
that's sort of filtered down
into various states for the
establishment of
these colleges.
So it's an interesting
process that happens.
That's important.
So there are moments when
I can imagine that big
government is a bad thing.
But there are also moments when
big government can be a
good thing.
In this instance, I think it
was not just good, it was
extremely important for the
future of the United States.
Think of the hundreds of
thousands of graduates who
have come out of
these colleges.
Not just MIT, but extremely
important to the development--
the economic development
of the country.
And that all started with a
federal piece of legislation.
DAVID MINDELL: We were just
talking during the break, the
21 names that signed
the MIT charter.
Rogers is one of them.
We know a little bit about a
couple of them, Roe and I, but
we don't know that much about
the rest of them.
They're not all names that you'd
instantly recognize.
But it's worth asking, in
addition to the government,
why would these presumably
prominent, moneyed Boston
people care about founding
this school?
What are their interest in it?
He wouldn't have been able
to do it by himself.
He needed this kind of social
group to support him.
PROFESSOR: Definitely.
DAVID MINDELL: It's a good paper
topic for someone, but
we should talk about it now.
Who are those 21 people?
PROFESSOR: That would be
a good topic, just
to look into one.
For example, just here's one
that I do know about, a guy
named James B Francis.
Has anyone ever heard
of him before?
I doubt it.
There's no reason you
should, probably.
But in his day, James B Francis
was probably the most
important hydraulic engineer,
surely in the United States,
if not the world.
He was very, very important.
He built the canal system in
Lowell, which was America's
leading industrial--
surely, leading water-powered
entity.
You can go up there today and
still see those power canals
that have been there for what,
200 years I suppose.
And he was responsible.
He's the guy that
engineered this.
And he was a close associate
of Rogers.
Rogers clearly recruited him or
told him about his vision
for this new polytechnic
institute.
And Francis immediately
signed on to it.
Now, Francis's papers exist
up in Lowell at the Lowell
Historical Society.
But I don't think anyone has
looked into, what was going on
between him and William
Rogers?
Were they having a
correspondence?
Probably they were.
I have no idea exactly.
What were they saying?
Where were they in concert
with one another?
Did they have disagreements?
I don't know, but he's an
example of this group of 21
that we don't know much
about that would be
interesting to know.
Where did that support come
from because they were
critical in supporting
the Institute.
So another guy who was involved
in that group is a
guy named Jacob Bigelow.
And he's the fellow who writes--
he's a Harvard
faculty member, isn't
he, for a while?
Interesting how many
Harvard people are
involved in this place.
Almost all the early faculty
are Harvard graduates,
believe it or not.
The early physicists are
Harvard graduates.
The chemists are Harvard
graduates.
Where else are they going
to get their staff?
There are some people that are
coming out of industry.
But the architecture department
here is founded by
a Harvard graduate,
a guy named Ware.
You'll read about
it next week.
But it's interesting that that
connection, there's this
tension and yet, connection at
the same time between these
two institutions that one tries
to take over the other
at least, what?
Five or six times during the
19th, early 20th centuries.
There's this very interesting
connection between those two
institutions that still
exists in many ways.
But it's this ongoing process
and the connections of Harvard
people joining MIT, being a part
of this whole process.
Bigelow being a Harvard person
who supports the
establishment of MIT.
Because they see a need.
Harvard has, supposedly,
an engineering program.
The Lawrence School was funded
by a textile magnate here,
local merchant who owned a lot
of textile mills in the area.
He gave Harvard--
I don't know, quite a big bundle
of money to try to
introduce an engineering
curriculum at Harvard.
And it never quite took off.
It was used for a lot of
different purposes, but it
never succeeded really,
in doing what Rogers
was doing down here.
And I think that's one of the
reasons why a lot of these
Harvard folks who had interests
in the practical
world, if you want to call it
that, gravitated toward MIT
when it was founded.
It's an interesting development
there, too.
Well, look, I'm talking.
Somebody's asking questions,
but I end up
talking about them.
So that's not a discussion.
That's a monologue.
I think from day one, there
was a research component
introduced into the
curriculum at MIT.
And that was through
laboratories.
In the days prior to
MIT's existence,
laboratories existed.
But they were primarily to--
you would hold demonstrations.
You would do chemical
experiments in front of the
students, but the students
were watching.
They weren't at the Bunsen
burner doing things, or
anything like that.
And with MIT, that changes.
One of Rogers'--
I think it's an innovation, is
to get students in the lab
doing things, doing research.
There's a fellow, trying
to remember his name.
He was educated here at MIT
as an undergraduate as a
physicist, who goes on to
found the electrical
engineering department at MIT.
Becomes a faculty member
after he graduates and
does graduate work.
I'm not sure if he does
it here or not.
Probably not.
Probably went to Germany,
or somewhere like that.
He founds the electrical
engineering department.
But it was all about his
writing a paper as an
undergraduate student in a
physics laboratory that he got
published that sent him on his
way toward this interesting
career as an academic
and as a researcher.
But the research orientation
of MIT has existed--
well, almost from day one.
That's interesting.
DAVID MINDELL: The idea of MIT
as a research institution
where the professors are doing
primarily research and then
the students sort of come
along and participate is
later, and not really until
the 20th century
does that get going.
I mean, students are always
working in the laboratories
for their own education.
But the fact that the professors
are leading these
big research programs,
that's not so much
there at the beginning.
PROFESSOR: OK, yeah.
DAVID MINDELL: There's
a distinction there.
PROFESSOR: You need to make
Yeah, OK.
But the guy's name I'm
thinking of is Cross,
C-R-O-S-S. And he actually did
research in an undergraduate
lab and resulted in the
publication of a paper.
That's research at one level.
But you're talking about
research, what?
Funded by the Air Force?
DAVID MINDELL: Or even by
foundations and things.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Well, that's true.
DAVID MINDELL: If you look
today, anybody know how much
of MIT's budget is undergraduate
tuition?
What percentage?
PROFESSOR: I have no idea.
DAVID MINDELL: Anybody
want to guess?
AUDIENCE: 20.
DAVID MINDELL: 20%?
AUDIENCE: 5%.
DAVID MINDELL: 5%?
AUDIENCE: Are we talking about
sources of money or what we
spend on it?
DAVID MINDELL: How much of
MIT's total budget--
if you add up the tuition that
each of you pay, forget about
financial aid for the moment.
Multiply it by the number of
undergraduates and put that
over the total budget of the
place, what's the proportion?
AUDIENCE: It's like 5%.
DAVID MINDELL: It's
like 5% or 10%.
It's pretty small.
And compare that to, like a
Williams College, where it's
close to 100%.
It's a very different place.
So that wasn't so much
true early on.
And even then, the tuition pays
a pretty small amount of
what it actually cost to educate
an undergraduate.
So that gives you some sense
of the orientation of the
place, where you have hundreds
of millions of dollars coming
from federal and other kinds of
sources to support research.
And students pay tuition, too.
And they're a big part of it.
And MIT does consider itself
educational in a big way.
But the research is just huge.
The model that's emerged, and it
really, in a way, took 100
of the 150 years, is
research-based education.
Which is a little different from
the early model of kind
of laboratory-based education.
So we'll see that over the
course of the next weeks as we
read about it that, you don't
have MIT professors winning
Nobel Prizes during
the 19th century.
If people want to get a PhD--
we mentioned this I
think last time--
in any of the sciences, they're
going to Germany.
Maybe to England, but
particularly to Germany to get
it well into the 20th century.
And the whole idea of graduate
education really comes in
around the turn of
the 20th century.
So in that sense,
it's different
from what it is today.
It's more like a kind of
undergraduate teaching--
maybe like Olin College.
Anybody ever heard of
Olin College out
in the suburbs here?
That probably is more like
what early MIT was
like than MIT today.
PROFESSOR: Interesting.
And that all, in many
ways, was modeled
after MIT, wasn't it?
There were a number of
MIT consultants.
It was Woodie Flowers,
and people like that.
DAVID MINDELL: I think Olin is
modeled after a lot of things
that are very hard to do at MIT,
which is why they were
able to do them.
PROFESSOR: Maybe that was it,
it was the wish list.
Well, that's interesting.
So from a corporate, government
research sort of
orientation, I guess the
corporate would be coming
first around World War I
thereabouts, under Maclaurin.
There was a president here named
Maclaurin who moved MIT
in a direction, I think, toward
applied research.
Was it called the technology
plan or something like that?
And we'll see more
of that later on.
Yeah, that's different than
what I'm talking about.
But the idea of getting students
in laboratories, and
having them literally use the
equipment, that's a new ball
game there.
Even that was novel.
DAVID MINDELL: One example there
that's worth looking
into is Alexander Graham Bell,
who's teaching here on campus.
Anybody know where he physically
actually invented
the telephone?
AUDIENCE: Wasn't it over
on Main Street?
DAVID MINDELL: Yeah, it was
downtown in Boston over
where-- basically where
Government Center is now.
There's a little teeny
plaque right there.
You can almost not notice it.
It says, this is
the place where
famous, "Come here, Watson.
I need you now," was.
But he didn't do that as
part of a lab at MIT.
Today you would think, of
course, if there was an
instructor here who was doing
research into telephony, he'd
be doing it on campus in a lab
with graduate students, and so
on and so forth.
That's not how it worked then.
He was doing it in his
own laboratory.
PROFESSOR: There's another
plaque over on Main Street.
Who mentioned Main Street?
Did you, Eric?
Isn't there a plaque on
Main Street that--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: Is that the
Polaroid one?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
a Polaroid building.
But I think it's a reference
to Alexander Graham Bell.
DAVID MINDELL: Maybe the first
exchange, which was when he
first got it going.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it could be.
I've forgotten what it is.
But I remember seeing it
as I was walking by.
AUDIENCE: He was an
instructor here.
He was teaching.
I'm not sure if he was actually
teaching at the
moment he made that invention.
I don't know how they
overlap together.
PROFESSOR: Interesting.
I have not encountered
that sort of
thought coming from him.
But I have to admit,
I have not read--
I have not been in the archives
to read everything
that he wrote at the time.
I suspect there are some
references there.
What I see, from the literature
I've been reading,
is primarily a concern about
just institution building.
I mean, he had a lot on his
plate just trying to get this
place started.
He was very sympathetic to
reform groups in Boston, the
abolitionist movement
being one of them.
There were a bunch of reform
movements that were underway
during the 1850s, abolitionism
being the most famous
probably, and the most
controversial.
But temperance against
drinking.
Wouldn't that be something if
William Barton Rogers was a
temperance advocate?
That could totally screw up
the 150th anniversary.
DAVID MINDELL: Or the entire--
PROFESSOR: I say that
as a house master.
DAVID MINDELL: Only a house
master would raise that issue.
PROFESSOR: Only a house master
could resonate to that.
I don't know.
But he was surely influenced
by these reform groups.
But his reform was
educational, no
question about it.
DAVID MINDELL: I think if you
look at how people like
Nathaniel Hawthorne responded
to the Civil War, there was
certainly a strain there.
He was a slightly earlier--
anybody ever heard of the
transcendentalists?
Obviously, Thoreau
and Emerson.
But then there were all these
other- Nathaniel Hawthorne,
Bronson Alcott, who was the
father of Louisa May Alcott,
who wrote Little Women, was a
very big educational reformer.
This was sort of more
in the 1830s, 1840s.
You read what these people
were writing.
They were basically like '60s
counterculture hippies of the
day in a certain way.
They were pretty radical.
There was free love movements
among them.
They were starting utopian
communities, all kinds of
wacky things there.
I don't think Rogers
really fell into
that category so much.
So people like Hawthorne and
Herman Melville later,
responded to the Civil War with
the question you asked
about, gee, is this just too
much industrialization?
Just leads to war.
Too much machinery, and it's all
dehumanizing and destroys
the environment.
There certainly were some
questions raised about that.
But I think William Barton
Rogers would say, not enough
rationality, not enough
science leads
people to act crazy.
We need better, more rational
management in the same way
that Roe was talking
about before.
PROFESSOR: That was his focus,
as best I can tell.
After he died, his wife edited
what she considered to be his
most important correspondence.
And that resulted in
a two-volume book.
Basically, of his letters.
And I've read a lot of them.
Can't say I've read every
one of them, but I've
read a lot of them.
And I don't remember
encountering the sort of
reform-oriented movements that
were very, very much in
evidence around here, other than
his distaste for slavery.
He clearly was not in
favor of slavery.
But on the other hand, I don't
think he was out there
attending anti-slavery rallies
and stuff like that.
He had his own vision of what
he wanted to do from an
educational perspective.
That took a lot of time,
just doing that.
Thinking about, how do you
form a curriculum?
Where do you get the money
to start the school?
How do you get the land?
Those are pretty daunting
questions when you're starting
from scratch, which he was.
He was not a wealthy man.
The first part of your question
is easy to answer,
and that is that it happened
fairly often.
If somebody passed away who
was a famous engineer,
oftentimes the wife, or a
cousin, or somebody would edit
the correspondence.
I think, for example, there's
like a 32-volume set of the
correspondence of Eleuthere
Irenee du Pont who was the
founder of the DuPont company.
Even earlier than Rogers in
the 19th century that was
edited by a woman who was a
descendant of his, but wasn't
one of his daughters
or even his wife.
But waited for probably 50
years before she got
interested in doing it.
So it varies about the time.
It may not happen five years
after a person's life.
It may happen 50 or 60
years afterwards.
But that happens.
You'll see it fairly often,
especially in the 19th century.
There are a few businesspeople
that do that.
The Appleton family here in
Boston are one of the founders
of the big textile mills
up in Lowell.
And there were several volumes
edited by their descendants of
their correspondence.
What were they trying
to achieve?
And clearly, that correspondence
is selective.
You got to ask yourself, well,
were they including every
letter in there?
Because most of that
correspondence is about the
vision they had for
the institution.
It was very rosy.
We have an obligation to be
stewards of what we have, and
we use our money to
promote things.
Very civic-spirited.
But on the other hand, there's
not a word in that
correspondence about the labor
management problems that
emerged during his lifetime.
Didn't he write anything
about that?
If so, where is it?
What happened to it in
the correspondence?
So those things have to be
looked at as something that
has been selective.
There's a process of
interpretation going on there,
as there is in all history.
Even I, when I write a book or
something, and working in
original archives, you
select facts to
construct your history.
And there are things that you
may leave out that David would
say are very important
that Smith ignored.
And that's one of the reasons
I became a historian, is I'm
very interested in how
do these differing
interpretations of
the past emerge?
And then, how do you
reconcile them once
those differences exist?
Because they keep getting
reconciled, and re-reconciled.
And it keeps going on.
DAVID MINDELL: The MIT archives
probably doesn't have
a collection of people who
thought William Barton Rogers
was an idiot and it was a
terrible idea to make this
Institute of Technology.
Those people may well
have existed.
And there may even be scattered
around in their
archives, around the
Massachusetts State Archives
of the Massachusetts Historical
Society, letters
that they wrote to
that effect.
But it's not something
that MIT has gone out
of its way to collect.
And so the archival record
tends to reflect--
well, it reflects the successes
and it also helps
make the successes.
So Barton Rogers' wife, by
compiling his letters,
undoubtedly she thought she was
doing it because he was a
historically important figure.
But collecting his letters and
publishing them also helps
make him into a historically
important figure.
And that's the kind of stuff
that historians and archivists
deal with all the time as far
as, what are the biases in
terms of what gets saved and
what gets thrown out?
And who's considered
important enough?
And who's not considered
important?
PROFESSOR: She wanted to
memorialize him for one thing.
I mean, that's why those two
volumes were published is as a
memorial to her husband, to
having done what she felt was
an important life's work.
But in the process, there's all
this selectivity that goes
on that sort of biases
the record.
So there's a lot of open
ends in all of
this study of history.
And especially, history of MIT
because so little has really
been published about it.
You were mentioning, Michelle,
collections of the MIT archives.
In certain ways, that archive
is one of the best in the
country for universities,
I think, if you look at
laboratories, or professors,
of people like that.
But if you were to ask--
go to the library and try
to find out much about
Burton-Conner house, or the
student housing system.
You don't find much there.
At least that's what the
boss told me one day.
That's been an area that wasn't
collected that I'm sure
is starting to be
collected now.
But different people have
different priorities.
And so there are things that
get forgotten or left out.
You keep adding, trying
to add to.
So student life is an important
element in all that.
DAVID MINDELL: Another question
that you all may
have, especially as we read next
week is, you look at 1865
when classes begin.
And suddenly there are people
like you in these rooms.
And the question is, who
were those people?
Were they children
of immigrants
who got a lucky break?
Were they children of people
in Boston with money who
decided that Harvard
wasn't for them?
Were they people who worked in
the Lowell mills who wanted to
get a more serious education?
We have very, very poor
documentation on just, who
were those early students?
Why did they come to this
place that no one
had ever heard of?
Because at the time, it wasn't
considered important.
They were considered
faces that were--
they weren't the president
and the benefactors.
As an historian, one needs
to get very creative
to think about it.
Now, some of those people ended
up becoming famous, and
wealthy, and preserved
their records, and
then gave them back.
And over time, you can piece
some of it together.
But there is no--
PROFESSOR: Compared with
Harvard, not as expensive?
But then, I don't know exactly
who paid for, say the use of
laboratory equipment.
Because I know the Institute
had a perennial problem in
trying to keep its laboratories
sufficiently equipped.
Now, did students have to pay
extra fees for that sort of--
if so, that would've
raised the tuition.
But I'd have to look that up.
I don't know.
DAVID MINDELL: I think we'll see
it in the reading in the
next couple weeks.
But it was not expensive.
It was not the way that
undergraduate education is
today where for a middle class
family it was really like
almost as expensive
as their house.
It was much more of a kind
of fee-based thing.
And I don't think it was
the major barrier.
It was not for poor people for
sure, but it was not the major
barrier to people coming.
Probably harder for people to
take those years away from the
workforce than it was
to pay the tuition.
PROFESSOR: And for many years,
I think through the 1870s and
in to the 1880s, most of the
students at MIT were not
full-time students.
They were special students.
And they were paying much
smaller fees because they were
basically people who were
working a 10-hour day, or
whatever it would be,
and then coming to
school at night primarily.
DAVID MINDELL: Not
living on campus.
PROFESSOR: And not living
on campus, yeah.
I'd have to look.
I'm not sure about Boston
University.
I don't think Boston University
was around at that
time, but I'd have to look.
I don't know.
Good question.
DAVID MINDELL: You'd have
Bowdoin in Maine.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, there are--
DAVID MINDELL: Williams
College I think was--
PROFESSOR: Amherst, Williams.
DAVID MINDELL: We
mentioned RPI.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
DAVID MINDELL: Most of the early
MIT students, there's
not great documentation
on this.
Most of them are from Boston
and pretty close by.
People didn't travel
the way they do
today to go to college.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The one piece of information
I know exists is there were
surveys done of where did
students come from, not so
much about their socioeconomic
backgrounds.
And it's interesting to
watch that circle.
Initially, strictly MIT
is a local school.
Most of the students that came
to it lived within a 20-mile
radius of the campus.
But then you see that
circumference getting larger,
and larger, and larger over
the first 30 or 40 years.
By the early 1900s, you have
students coming here from all
parts of the United States.
By the 1890s, for example, the
DuPont family were sending
some of their sons up
here to school.
The most important being a guy
named Pierre DuPont who became
not only the head of the DuPont
Company, but the boss
of General Motors
for many years.
Really, made General Motors into
the big corporation that
it is, with the help
of Alfred Sloan.
I think DuPont may have hired
him, I'm not sure.
But Sloan was a graduate
of MIT.
DAVID MINDELL: Why was a
chemical company involved in
the auto industry?
That's a question
you could ask.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
Why was the chemical company
of DuPont involved in the
automobile industry?
Good question.
AUDIENCE: Deals?
Deals in oil--
PROFESSOR: Not really, no.
Think of that.
Who's the chemical engineer
in the class?
Any chemical engineers,
chemists?
What do you guess?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
DAVID MINDELL: What part of
a car was made by DuPont?
That's another way to ask it.
AUDIENCE: Paint.
PROFESSOR: Paint, yeah.
It's the paint.
GM bought all their
paint from DuPont.
And then, I think got in trouble
economically, and
DuPont took over the company,
or a large chunk of the
company in order to resuscitate
it and get their
investment back out of it.
That's when Pierre went in
there and basically took
things over.
Yeah, it's all about
paint for DuPont.
AUDIENCE: I feel like that's a
non-essential part of a car.
PROFESSOR: But it's
a big part.
By the 1910s, it's a big
business and a big account
that you would have.
DAVID MINDELL: It's off-track
a little bit, but Henry Ford
was famous for saying you can
have a Model T In any color as
long as it's black.
And one of the ways that
General Motors then
differentiated itself was both
an annual model change where
it wasn't so standardized and
you could get cars in
different colors.
PROFESSOR: And Sloan was right
in the middle of all that.
Absolutely.
Any other questions?
People were very tight with
their pocketbooks.
You'll see next week in the
essay that I've written, I
make an argument in there that
government support was very
important because once potential
private donors saw
that the state of Massachusetts
was investing in
MIT with land and money, that
gave private donors a signal
that this institution
had a future.
That they took more confidence
in the possibility of this
actually taking root
and going forward.
So the guy that wrote that
letter was the doctor.
I think he gave $40,000
in 1864.
That was a huge amount
of money.
And that was partly because--
he gave the money because he saw
the state of Massachusetts
investing in MIT and
thought, OK, they
got a chance to survive.
I will help them out.
So that's very important.
DAVID MINDELL: There's a case to
be made, it came up when we
were making that video.
That even though the war was
so disruptive to Rogers'
plans, there's a case to be made
that having four years
kind of hiatus before really
having to get the place going
gave him the time and the
background to get it a little
bit more established
financially and
institutionally before
teaching classes.
Where you'd think, as soon as
you get the charter signed,
you admit students
the next fall.
Well, then you're both running
the place and planning it at
the same time, and this
way he was able to.
And then, at some point-- and
it would be interesting to
look at when this point is--
it became clear the war was
going to be won at some point
by the North.
And some people probably
believed
that from the beginning.
And then there was a big
reconstruction job to be done.
And there was at least some
kind of sense of optimism.
And that's probably when some of
the momentum around 1860--
I'm sure the second half of
1863, 1864 after Gettysburg,
it was not a done deal but
the tide had turned.
And so there was people
looking forward
and thinking about--
there's a lot of building
to be done after a war.
If you're an Iraqi businessman
in 2002, you'd be investing in
construction equipment,
because that's
what you got to do.
PROFESSOR: Well, the Morrill
Land-Grant Act, which is the
background to all of these state
universities basically,
that wasn't passed until
the summer of 1862.
So Rogers, really wouldn't have
had anything to build on.
If that act hadn't been
past, he would
have been in big trouble.
Because no one was ponying up
with free land over in Back
Bay other than the state of
Massachusetts, who he had to
do a lot of lobbying with.
One of the things that
suited him well--
I should mention this-- was
that Rogers was a very
effective small "p" politician,
in the sense that
he knew how to lobby people.
And how did he learn that?
He learned it through a very
bitter experience that he had
had in Virginia as the head of
the state survey in which he
learned how mean-spirited
politics could be.
And he really became very astute
at learning how to
approach legislators, people
like that, to get their
support for voting funds for
this new institution that he
was trying to establish.
So even though he had a bad
experience in Virginia with
the geological survey, it served
him well in the long
run in learning how to negotiate
the building of a
new educational institute
here in Boston.
He was a smart man, no
doubt about that.
It's hard to get a read on what
kind of person was he.
I mean, we know about his
intellectual qualities.
Obviously, very smart,
very bright, capable.
But did people call
him William?
Did they call him Billy?
They call him Will?
Did he have a nickname?
You see his pictures.
If you were to judge from his
pictures, you always called
him William, or Mr. Rogers,
or something like that.
Yeah, Mr. Rogers.
A double entendre there.
But he's a hard person
to try to get a sense
of, what was he like?
Clearly, very good
with people.
But at the same time, he
looks as if he's a
fairly formal person.
He was raised in a Scots Irish
family, so it was probably a
fairly strict upbringing
that he had.
Is he a religious person?
I've not seen any references
to being a deeply religious
person, though probably he was
maybe a Presbyterian coming
from that sort of background.
I don't know.
It's possible to find that
out, I just don't know.
AUDIENCE: How long was he
actually active here once
classes started?
PROFESSOR: Well, he
died in 1883.
And he was very active.
I'm trying to remember.
Around-- was it 1873?
I've forgotten.
He serves as president
twice, basically.
He serves a stint getting
the thing started.
And then he has a
health problem.
He starts having health
problems in the 1870s.
And he backs off and he turns
over the Institute to one of
his most trusted associates.
And that goes on until
around 18--
I'm trying to remember
the dates here.
'79, 80 thereabouts, I think.
AUDIENCE: It says that he
returned in '78 and continued
until 1881.
PROFESSOR: '81, OK.
And that's sort of the
interim president.
He was not a well person at that
time, but he was sort of
filling in until they could find
a new president and the
new president was Francis
Amasa Walker?
AUDIENCE: I believe so.
PROFESSOR: Speaking of
the Civil War, Fran--
now, he did have a nickname.
His name was Frank.
People did call him
Frank Walker.
But Francis Amasa Walker was
a Civil War general.
Had earned ribbons and things
for service during the war.
And then he was--
as I remember, he was educated,
I believe, at
Amherst and Yale.
He went to Yale as
a professor.
He would have been by our lights
today, someone who was
in economics.
He was not an engineer
or scientist.
And he became very famous for
running the US Census of 1880,
which was arguably the
best US Census done
during the 19th century.
Extremely well done.
And even today, you can read
it and get a lot of good
information out of it about
all sorts of things, from
cotton harvesting to
manufacturing processes.
But he was in charge of that.
And then, he came to MIT from
the Census Office in
Washington, basically.
He'd been on leave at Yale and
came up here after that.
So he came here in
'83 did you say?
AUDIENCE: Oops.
I had it up here a second ago.
It has him '81 to
1897 it seems.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Well, it's right around in there
because the US Census
was finished by '82,
or thereabouts.
And Rogers dies on the platform
of Francis Amasa
Walker's inaugural day.
He's literally giving a speech
and keels over and passes away
on the platform when he's
transferring power, in effect,
formally to the new president.
So he dies in '83.
So that would have meant that
Walker arrived somewhere in
the previous year.
DAVID MINDELL: It's worth
talking then a little bit
about the postwar years.
The classes start here right at
the end of the war, but in
terms of the US economy, it
really takes the better part
of a decade to recover from
the wounds of the war.
And you can think about 1876,
which is the centennial year.
There's a big exposition in--
PROFESSOR: Philadelphia.
DAVID MINDELL: --Philadelphia,
which features a lot of
American technology.
The telegraph makes its first
sort of public debut there for
the first time.
PROFESSOR: Telephone.
You mean the telephone.
DAVID MINDELL: Telephone.
Telephone makes public
debut there.
Edison's electric light
is really 1881.
And so the kind of industrial,
sometimes it's called the
second Industrial Revolution
after the Civil War, takes a
while to get going.
And it really takes 10 or 15
years for the country to get
out of the tunnel and the kind
of malaise of recovering from
this national catastrophe.
And many of those industrialists
that--
Andrew Carnegie's and even
Thomas Edison's, these are not
people who served in
the Civil War.
They're just a little younger
than that, or they were doing
other things during the war.
And the big US Navy sort of
turns its attention towards
steel only in 1883.
And those industries,
it's a while.
In a sense, Rogers is sort of
a product of the generation
before the war.
It's people like Walker and
others who really take up the
call after the war.
And it takes a while for
that era to get going.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I think it's during Walker's
administration that MIT really
starts to take off as an
educational institution.
Someone was saying, how many
students are living on campus?
It's during his administration
that you go to full-time
students away from
special students.
It's during his administration
that the majority of students
then are full-time students.
I don't know about
dormitories.
I think they did not have dorms
in those days that I'm
familiar with.
They probably had to find
rooms in the city
or things like that.
I don't think dormitories appear
until the new campus is
built over here.
Senior House is the first dorm,
isn't it, on campus?
DAVID MINDELL: Is it?
PROFESSOR: I think it is.
DAVID MINDELL: MIT doesn't
become predominantly
residential until
the '50s really.
PROFESSOR: Are you
Senior House?
AUDIENCE: No, but
I [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I think that's
the oldest of the
dorms, is Senior House.
If that's the case, then we're
talking around 1917, 1918.
Because I think that's
built after the
main campus is built.
It's built right around the same
time that the President's
House is built.
So that's pretty late.
But the shift during
Walker's years was
important because he gives--
you read it in my essay that
he gives an annual report.
I think it's in 1894, in which
he sort of ends the report by
saying the battle of
the New Education--
and New Education are
capitalized--
has been won.
And what he means by that
is that MIT's program of
education was called the New
Education by none other than
the president of Harvard.
A guy named Charles Eliot, who
started his teaching career
here at MIT in the chemistry
department.
And then he was here for about
two years, and then Harvard
hired him as president of
Harvard University.
So there's all of this
back and forth
between Harvard and MIT.
But Eliot coins the phrase--
he writes a two-part essay in
The Atlantic magazine, which
is still being published, called
"The New Education." I
think part of it, in fact, you
have to read for next week.
But it's really about MIT.
This is this new education
that's so different from all
the old classical curricula
that's around.
DAVID MINDELL: That's
30 years.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
DAVID MINDELL: Which is also
what about the amount of time
it takes graduates from the
first classes to rise up
through the ranks of whatever
field they're in and become
senior people.
And either start giving money
back, or become prominent
scientists in their fields, or
whatever kinds of career
success they have.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
an interesting point.
DAVID MINDELL: It's a
generation, basically.
PROFESSOR: The person to put
up the money to build this
campus, do you know
who it was?
Well, you'll encounter
it in the reading.
George Eastman from Rochester,
New York.
Eastman Kodak was the guy who
put up most of the money for
the building of this campus.
But he didn't buy the
land over here.
Or he didn't give the
money for the land.
The land had already
been purchased.
That money came from the du
Ponts, who were graduates,
former graduates.
And they were all products
of the 1890s.
They would have been here when
Walker was president.
By the time of the World War
I, they had emerged as
business leaders, very wealthy
people, and were capable of
endowing the Institute
with land over here.
So it's not just all George
Eastman though.
Most of it was.
He was amazingly generous with
President Maclaurin about
giving money to the Institute.
And I think I may have mentioned
this last time that
there were moments
when he'd write--
I don't know, huge, huge amount
of money for the time.
But MIT would discover that it
wasn't quite enough and they'd
go back to Mr. Eastman
for more support.
And he would write
another check.
And he ponied up.
I don't know, at least three
times, I think, in which
President Maclaurin went back
and said, we don't quite have
enough Mr. Eastman.
And he would--
and the reason why according to
the records that exist that
he did that was that he was
not a graduate of MIT.
He had no personal connection
with the place, but a lot of
his employees were
MIT graduates.
And he was so impressed by their
abilities that he felt
that this was a good
place to endow.
So it's a very interesting--
DAVID MINDELL: A company like
Kodak is a second Industrial
Revolution company in a way
where you can't even have a
company like that
without trained
chemists and some PhDs.
And the electrical industry
is the same way.
Even the steel industry
to some degree.
It was quite different from the
early railroads and the
Lowell mills where a lot of
good tinkerers getting
together could really
make the thing work.
These sort of second wave
companies are what you would
today call high-tech companies,
where it's not
something you're going to come
up with in your garage is the
way to make film.
Rubber is that way.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
that started that Harvard
tried to buy MIT?
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, it wasn't
so much buying, it was
amalgamating with it.
The first attempt happened
during the 1870s, I think.
Not long after Charles Eliot
became president.
See, he was hired here.
Eliot was hired here as a
professor of chemistry around
1867 if memory serves.
He was here for roughly two
years, and then he was called
to Harvard as president there.
And he had written this article
called "The New
Education," which he was,
in effect, sounding
the glories of MIT.
Saying, this is the
way, folks.
This is the New Education.
So when he went to Harvard, he
wanted to try to reconfigure
Harvard's system along the lines
of MIT. and what better
way to do it than to absorb MIT
into the Harvard system.
So the first attempt was made
fairly early in his
presidency.
I would say as early
as 1873 or '74.
There will be an essay in the
book that we're reading about
that subject.
It goes through all
the different--
DAVID MINDELL: Even in 1861,
I think as the governor is
signing the charter, he looks up
and he says to Rogers, why
aren't you guys getting together
with Harvard and
doing this?
PROFESSOR: Right,
Governor Andrew.
There were efforts even-- yeah,
even during the charter
phase that the governor of
Massachusetts who was a
Harvard graduate said,
wait a minute.
Why do you want to do this
separately from Harvard?
Why don't you do it in
concert with Harvard?
And so Rogers was constantly
being sort of put upon about
trying to nudge up
against Harvard.
And, of course, his resistance
was he was fearful that his
vision would not be enacted
at Harvard.
Plus, he had some intellectual
enemies there.
Agassiz was one of them.
His primary intellectual
opponent, and continued to be
one well into the 1870s.
It's an ongoing process.
As I said earlier, it happens
at least five or six times.
Harvard did not give up
after one attempt.
They kept doing it.
And Eliot was the most avid of
all about trying to absorb MIT
into Harvard because
he had been here.
He had seen what was good about
the place, and wanted it
moved into Harvard.
DAVID MINDELL: How many of you
today would vote in favor of a
merger with Harvard?
That's about how it came out
in the 19th century also.
PROFESSOR: That was
just about right.
Now, how many of you would
vote for a merger, say if
somebody gave you $50,000?
Wouldn't do it anyway.
See, this is true believer
territory here.
Good.
AUDIENCE: The time was
it that obvious, too?
Or was there more debate?
PROFESSOR: As I recollect in the
first time around, it was
pretty cut and dry.
People here were saying, no,
we don't need to do that.
But later on, it came
very close.
During the early 1900s, there
was a moment when Harvard and
MIT became very close.
I think it was President
Pritchard who actually
approved a merger.
And then, that kind of got
opposition and backed off.
And this will be discussed
later.
But there was a moment when MIT
and Harvard were actually
granting joint degrees if
I'm not mistaken for
a very brief time.
DAVID MINDELL: Yeah, it only
failed because the
Massachusetts Supreme Court
ruled, however, that they're
not allowed to spend the money
they were using for it for
that purpose.
PROFESSOR: It came close
to happening in
the early 20th century.
William Rogers must have rolled
over on his grave.
DAVID MINDELL: I think there
were moments where it came
down to MIT might close if it
didn't find itself financially
more support.
And so it was under those
kind of stresses.
But I think once there's a
community of alums, they felt
pretty strongly that it
should stay as it is.
That's in the reading
for next week.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
interesting, too, that that
discussion of mergers really
fades after Maclaurin has this
campus built over here, gets
the Eastman money.
MIT then is pretty well
defining its own life.
And that sort of fades
off the screen.
AUDIENCE: Why is the merger
discussion so one-sided?
Why does Harvard want to merge
with MIT, but MIT not want to
merge with Harvard?
PROFESSOR: Well, I know the
Rogers side of the story is
that he was fearful that if
that merger were to take
place, that the core programs
that he wanted to see
introduced, like laboratories
for students, an emphasis on
science interacting with
practical applications, would
eventually fall by
the wayside.
Because they were fearful of
Harvard's emphasis on the
traditional liberal arts.
Harvard is, to this day in
many ways, controlled by
humanities faculty, or social
science humanities faculties,
rather than science faculty.
AUDIENCE: So then why would
Harvard so badly want
to merge with MIT?
PROFESSOR: Why?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Because it was MIT
It was the cutting edge.
It was the New Education.
It was the new way of doing
science and engineering, which
they felt they wanted
to incorporate in
to the Harvard system.
DAVID MINDELL: Well, sort of the
opposite problem they had,
which was that they
couldn't manage to
start it on their own.
They tried in a number
of different ways.
PROFESSOR: It never worked.
DAVID MINDELL: And their
attempts to do technical
education were always co-opted
by the more old school
scientists who saw
it as natural
philosophy and not so much--
you also got to remember, MIT's
celebrating its 150th
anniversary this year.
What was the last anniversary
Harvard celebrated?
Anybody remember?
You probably weren't
here for it.
Because it was already almost
10 years ago, I think.
350.
So they have 200 years on MIT.
Big difference.
How many MIT graduates have
been in the White House?
Zero.
How many Harvard graduates have
been in the White House?
Quite a number of them.
How many Harvard graduates
are in Congress?
Lots of them.
Senators?
All over the place.
Very, very different
sort of social
structure to that school.
PROFESSOR: It is a different
breed of cat.
DAVID MINDELL: Harvard played
a big role in the American
Revolution.
Harvard graduates played a
big role in the American
Revolution, which
we can't claim.
PROFESSOR: But there were
MIT graduates who fought
in the Civil War.
DAVID MINDELL: There were?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
They came back after the war
and went to school here.
But they fought in
the Civil War.
They survived.
They were survivors.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I know this is much
later, but when did MIT become
a great economic--
[INAUDIBLE], economics--
PROFESSOR: I think that probably
dates from the
arrival of Paul Samuelson as a
professor of economics here.
And that would have been
after World War II.
DAVID MINDELL: Yeah, he came
during World War II.
PROFESSOR: You're familiar
with Paul Samuelson?
He just died, what?
About a year ago.
Very famous economist.
Arguably the most--
he wrote a textbook in economics
that I used as a
college student.
And it was like in its seventh
edition when I used it.
And it's been used
over the years in
general economics classes.
So he became very famous
for his textbook.
That was the leading textbook
in economics for many years.
And then, he won
a Nobel Prize.
And that department has won
a lot of Nobel Prizes.
And so under his leadership
and others-- he wasn't the
only one there-- but Robert
Solow is another very famous
economist who is now retired,
but is very
active around here.
They really brokered that
department into one of the
best in the world.
And ti still is.
I think it's still considered
to be one of the top
departments in the
United States.
DAVID MINDELL: But that's
post-World War II.
PROFESSOR: It's post-World
War II.
Yeah, definitely.
DAVID MINDELL: I mean, directly
post-World War II.
Samuelson came here and
he worked in the
radiation lab on radar.
PROFESSOR: Did he?
I didn't know that.
Interesting.
Well, good.
Now, we'll stop at this point.
We'll continue talking
about this era.
I want to really focus
on Rogers next week.
We focused a lot on him today,
I don't know there's a whole
lot more to say.
But there will be.
I want you to read the essay
about him and read some of
those primary documents, just to
get a sense of what they're
talking about there.
That article about the New
Education is worthwhile
because it's really making a
proclamation to the rest of
the country about there's
something new and different
going on here in Boston,
and it's MIT.
It's that sort of argument
that's being made there.
These are not the most
scintillating papers to read
in the world.
So work through them.
Read them.
You don't have to study
them closely.
We're just trying to give
you a taste of what that
formalistic literature looked
like in those days.
But you got to look at to get
a sense of, what was it?
Yo don't need to memorize
it, just get a
sense of what it was.